This first graph represents f minus g of x, and this last graph represents g
minus f of x. For f minus g here, we see something very similar to what
happened when we added f and g together. Since we're just subtracting a
constant function from this linear one, we end up with the same exact graph as
f. We can see that this line is parallel to this one, except this one is
shifted down three units. G minus f is a bit more complicated. In this case,
we're subtracting our linear function from our constant one. This means that
the resulting graph isn't just going to be a shift of f. Instead, for each
value of x. [INAUDIBLE]. We measure from the x axis to the line of f. Then, we
look at the graph of g. And we move it down by the positive distances between
the x axis and f, shown by these lines right here. And up by those distances
between the x axis and the part of f that lay below it. We're adding this
positive distance because we were subtracting a negative one before. If we
connect the tops of all these lines together, we can see that we will end up
with a graph that looks just like this one, to the far right. What's
interesting, is that now our slope is negative. It's not positive or zero, like
either of our two original functions.